There is no doubt that fraud is a global concern.
In 2005, Unisys conducted a survey...
...into the increasing prevalence of online identity theft.
At that time, 17% of US and 11% of UK consumers reported being a victim.
In 2006, a Gartner research survey...
...found a 50% increase in ID theft victims compared to 2003.
All the evidence shows that...
...as the acceptance of financial products such as credit cards grows,...
...the risk of ID fraud also increases.
What seems obvious is that banks and their customers...
...have a responsibility for remaining vigilant and up-to-date...
...with online security measures in order to protect themselves from Internet hackers.
Some people claim that biometric data, such as iris scans and fingerprints,...
...could provide the answer.
However, it could be argued that this will not solve the problem,...
...as the usefulness of biometrics depends on the quality...
...and therefore the cost of the machine and the technology used.
Other people favour "two-factor identification."
In addition to a password, confirmation by cellphone is required.
Two-factor identification puts another step in the way of criminals.